After the farmer
and the pie chain
get involved in this
forward contract,
a few questions start to pop
up in each of their minds.
The main one is, what
if the other party isn't
able to uphold their
end of the contract?
And this is called counterparty
risk, which is essentially,
the counterparty to the
farmer is the pie store.
And the counterparty to the
pie chain is the farmer.
It is the risk that
the other party
won't be able to uphold
their end of the contract.
The other thing that starts
to worry either one of these
is what if they start
to have second thoughts
about this forward
contract they entered into.
Would they be able to
maybe sell their obligation
to someone else?
So is there any way
to trade the contract?
And then there's another
issue, that even if you
were to trade the
contract, how do
we know that the other party
to the whoever you might want
to trade with would be cool with
a million pounds, or $200,000.
Maybe they would want to
deal with a smaller quantity.
Maybe they would only
want 1,000 pounds
or $100,000 worth of apples.
So the local brain
comes up with an idea.
He's like, why
don't we standardize
these forward contracts?
Why don't I just create a
bunch of contracts, whenever
someone wants to enter to one
of these forward contract,
but I standardize them.
And I say that it is 1,000,
instead of having a million
apples, I do a small
enough increment.
So I say 1,000 pounds of apples
for the delivery on let's say
on November 15.
And every one of these
contracts say the same thing.
1,000 pounds of apples
for delivery on 11/15.
And this guy, he's also
the richest guy in town.
He's already been
running a stock exchange.
And so to help alleviate
the counterparty risk fear,
he also says that I'm
going to guarantee
any of these contracts.
So essentially he's taking on
all of the counterparty risk
to make people more
comfortable with trading.
So all of a sudden, what
happens is that now these guys
don't have to do a
one off contract.
They don't have to do this
one off the forward contract.
There are these
standardized contracts
that this exchange
can now trade.
And what happens is
that smaller farmers.
Let me do this in
a different color.
You have farmer A,
farmer B. Farmer B
can now can now transact
with, I should say,
I guess we could call it
customer C and customer D.
Where they could agree
to have a fixed price,
but they could do
smaller increments,
more granular increments.
And if any of them
want to get out of it,
they can by selling
their contract
to another person
on the exchange.
And these more standardized
forward contracts, they're
still essentially
the same thing.
They're just standardized.
They're agreements to
transact at a future date,
give a certain amount of
money for a certain amount
of something else.
It could be a security.
It could be apples.
These things, these standardized
forward contracts, these
are called futures, where
they're standardized,
and they are traded
on an exchange.